[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal
guten abend ihnen allen im krieg sind
solidarität und einigkeit gefragt zum
beispiel in der nato wo sich mitglieder
ja eigentlich partner nennen die nato
länder griechenland und türkei aber
würden sich wohl eher als feinde
bezeichnet
seit vielen jahren eskaliert es immer
wieder wegen gebietsansprüchen im
mittelmeer oder dortigen erdgasvorkommen
aussenministerin baerbock war heute in
beiden ländern zu besuch sie erklärte
sich solidarisch mit athen wofür später
ein entsprechend eisiges echo in
istanbul gab auch deswegen schwierig
weil die türkei aktuell im ukraine krieg
stichwort getreide deal eine
schlüsselrolle einnimmt mehr von
luckwald bot die liste der themen war
lang der umgangston zunächst herzlich
mein freund matt nannte berbalk den
amtskollegen sie lobte die türkische
vermittlung beim getreide abkommen
cavusoglu die engen
wirtschaftsbeziehungen zu deutschland
die differenzen konnte das nicht
verdecken und sie sind beträchtlich sich
gegenseitig zuhören auch wenn einem
dabei die ohren schmerzen so sagte
baerbock ein beispiel urteile des
europäischen gerichtshofs für
menschenrechte seien zu beachten und
zwar ausnahmslos und zu jeder zeit dazu
gehört für mich auch die vom
europäischen gerichtshof für
menschenrechte
angeordnete freilassung von osman kavala
mir ist bewusst dass es in diesen zeiten
schwierig ist über themen zu reden wo
wir auch in seiner pressekonferenz beide
vielleicht zucken beim zocken beließ
cavusoglu es nicht auch andere staaten
würden urteile des menschengerichtshofs
nicht umsetzen griechenland zum beispiel
frau bekommt ja gerade aus griechenland
sie erwähnt hier aber nicht dass athen
seit 14 jahren ein gerichtsurteil zum
schutz türkischer minderheiten
verschleppt schon am morgen in athen
hatte berbalk klar gemacht dass sie im
streit zwischen der türkei und
griechenland um die ägäis inseln klar an
der seite griechenlands stehen
und viele viele andere
und niemand hat das recht
eine stellungnahme die den türkischen
außenminister am abend veranlasste
undiplomatisch deutlich gegen bernburg
auszuteilen
frau merkel war steht seine aufrichtige
vermittlerin ich verlange nicht dass sie
unsere sicht übernehmen aber wir
erwarten von deutschland dass es
unparteiische und verbleibt davor haben
wir respekt
einig war man sich aber dass die türkei
ihre wertvolle vermittlerrolle zwischen
russland und der ukraine im hinblick auf
eine beendigung des krieges weiter
nutzen sollte eine folge der türkischen
bemühungen in odessa wurden heute erste
frachtschiffe mit getreide für den
export beladen präsident selensky war
eigens angereist
sobald wir von den vereinten nationen
und der türkei das signal erhalten kann
das erste schiff auslaufen
wahrscheinlich heute oder morgen
ein hoffnungsschimmer für die ukraine
und für millionen menschen die auf das
getreide warten
wir gehen nach istanbul zurück war also
noch haben die getreidefelder sei nicht
abgelegt gibt es neuigkeiten
also das heißt sowohl aus soll deshalb
auch von den vereinten nationen dass es
nur noch einen kleinen details hängt zum
beispiel die fahrrinne die noch nicht
hundertprozentig festgelegt ist liegen
ja auf minen vor dem hafen aber es sieht
so aus als wenn am wochenende vielleicht
morgen schon oder spätestens am sonntag
das erste schiff ablegen kann zumindest
für den getreide deal hatte berbalk
heute lob übrig aber ansonsten hat man
sich ja einiges um die ohren gehauen wie
schätzt du das 1
ja das war sagen wir mal robusten ist
rustikal
was wir heute erlebt haben bei der
pressekonferenz aber vielleicht ein ganz
klarer kluger schachzug von
außenministerin baerbock hier nicht sie
sagte wörtlich freundschaft bedeutet
nicht plattitüden auszutauschen sie hat
hier eine klare ansage gemacht übrigens
wesentlich klarer als noch im mai beim
antrittsbesuch von bundeskanzler scholz
da ging es noch recht verbindlich zu
zwischen scholz und erdogan man hat sich
nicht allzu sehr die wahrheit gesagt und
es dem unverbindlichen geblieben heute
war das sehr robust und das ist wie
gesagt eigentlich ein neuer ton und
darauf wird sich die türkei ein stellen
das ist klar aber es ist nicht unklug
für klare verhältnisse zu sorgen und
klar zu sagen wo man steht
möglicherweise für das im direkten
gespräch mit der türkischen regierung zu
mehr vorankommen zu mehr erfolgen als in
der vergangenheit danke nach istanbul
lück wallbott auf den offiziellen
kanälen monate lang funkstille aber
jetzt hat us aussenminister zum ersten
mal seit kriegsbeginn mit dem russischen
aussenminister gesprochen er soll ein
offenes gespräch gewesen sein
us-außenminister blinken erklärte nach
dem telefonat er habe lavrov gesagt dass
die welt niemals eine annexion
ukrainischer gebiete akzeptieren werde
außerdem habe er lavrov dazu gedrängt
einem angebot zur freilassung zweier in
russland inhaftierte us-bürger
zuzustimmen
deutschland will der ukraine 16 brücken
lege panzer vom typ bieber liefern sechs
davon noch in diesem jahr damit sollen
die ukrainischen truppen gewässer und
gräben überbrücken können russland und
die ukraine werfen sich gegenseitig vor
für explosionen in einem gefängnis in
der region donetsk verantwortlich zu
sein dabei wurden mindestens 50 menschen
getötet
laut russischen verteidigungsministerium
ukrainische kriegsgefangene
zur besseren vorsorge in der drohenden
energiekrise gelten seit heute strengere
vorschriften für den füllstand der
gasspeicher bis zum ersten september
sollen sie zu 75 prozent gefüllt sein
bis november dann zu 95 prozent aktuell
liegen die füllmengen bei rund 67
prozent
die inflation hat im euroraum im juli
einen neuen höchststand von 8,9 prozent
erreicht preistreiber waren in folge des
krieges erneut energie und kraftstoffe
sowie lebensmittel in den baltischen
staaten ist die rate mit über 20 prozent
am höchsten
die deutsche wirtschaft ist im
frühsommer nicht gewachsen laut
statistischem bundesamt stagnierte sie
im vergleich zum vorjahr wegen der
erfassung der ukraine geflüchteten
steigt die zahl der arbeitslosen auf
juli 2,47 millionen das sind 100 7000
mehr als im juni die quote steigt auf
5,4 prozent im vergleich zum vorjahr
sind
120.000 menschen weniger arbeitslos
china gundula england hat nur einen
internationalen fußball titel gewonnen
1966 mann wurde einige werden sich
schmerzhaft erinnern dank des wembley
tores gegen deutschland
fußballweltmeister danach bis heute
flaute die duelle entschied häufig
deutschland für sich und so entstand der
mythos der unbesiegbaren deutschen
übermorgen aber haben englands
fußballerinnen in eben jenem und
heimischen wembley stadion die chance
das em finale zu gewinnen allerdings
geht es ja gegen deutschland über
englands fußball fieber andreas stamm
noch mal hand anlegen feinschliff für
das finale
der trainingsplatz noch mit
baustellencharakter doch es wartet ein
heiliger rasen und drei worte die seit
langem die fußballwelt elektrisieren
england deutschland wembley
sind natürlich euphorisch freuen uns auf
die atmosphäre auf das stadion auf den
gegner ich denke das wird ein spiel das
wir
nicht mehr ganz so häufig erleben werden
in der karriere von da ist die vorfreude
riesig
auf einen gegner die löwen die für ein
nie gekanntes maß an frauen fußball
begeisterung auf der insel sorgen
volle fanmeilen party im halbfinale
zuschauerrekorde in den stadien in tv
ein volksfest
[Applaus]
nicht so gigantisch wie bei den männern
noch nicht
die qualität der spiele das
fußballerische können die
geschwindigkeit sie müssen sich nicht
mehr vor den männern verstecken dazu die
fantastische atmosphäre nun aggressiv
besser als bei jedem männer match
verrückt so inspirierend das
mitzuerleben brillant ich bin so
überglücklich
sinnbild für die familien feststimmung
der halbfinal sie tanz von test dohlen
der die achtjährige nachwuchs
kickerinnen aus manchester zum
medienliebling und orakel katapultiert
sie haben eine gute denkweise denken
darüber nach was sie als nächstes tun
nicht den ball einfach nach vorne
dreschen gegen deutschland reicht das
für einen 32
doch keine fußball-nation weiß so gut
wie england wie schnell aus euphorie
elend werden kann vor diesem finale hat
die angst einnahmen pop panik
andere spielerinnen sind stark aber pop
sie will es unbedingt das spürt und
sieht man
alles bereit für ein fußball final fest
in einer kathedrale des sports wie
gesagt england deutschland wembley und
hier fehlen noch die wetteraussichten
freundlich und trocken wird es morgen
nur im nordosten und westen sonst teils
kräftige schauer und gewitter 20 bis 30
grad in den nächsten tagen im norden
wechselhaft im süden sonnig und dort
auch wieder zunehmend heiß bis zu 35
grad ja das war es auch schon wieder von
uns ihnen jetzt noch viel spaß bei der
zweiten halbzeit und bis morgen schönen
abend tschüss und bis morgen
[Musik]